I'm gonna put a line there and this foot
all the way around etext you're gonna
fake that line now that's the point of
no return this is the head you requested
yeah there was something easy what up
guys I'm daddy Ramazan II I've been
lookin crusty like most of you during
quarantine I don't usually let my hair
go out this much I like to keep it real
I got this guy right here my brother
tell me your name Ben Ben I'm Ronnie and
I'm cutting his hair today we got a
professional barber mark out in England
is gonna be helping us out
he sent mark a photo of what my hair
used to look like and we go see a band
can recreate it you think I can cut your
hair after no I've never lived cut my
hair never ever good I'm good I'm
excited that you're black because I was
nervous at first when they were like we
got a bar brawls I don't wait because I
come up here looking for the directions
[Music]
all right so guys let me get a look at
your head and let me know what kind of
stuff like I haven't had a haircut since
probably like a few weeks after
Valentine's Day it's generally just like
cutting it up like super low on top and
just fading everywhere else I'm
confidence
on the side okay so now we can get into
the car and me helping you go through
this I'm not gonna go through every
single detail I just want to give you
the bare minimum to get you through the
haircut because ultimately you know
you're not training to be a barber
you're trying to keep so you just follow
along but I think I'm saying it to you
it won't be good
you're gonna start by using a - you know
a lot of different growth and direction
that you know someone's Jack Rosen it's
always applying to go of a higher level
first so you can bring it down and then
you can look at the hair and see the
growth of direction if you go with a
number one issue with a rounded point
here if you get it wrong you might end
up with a pattern you said so when
you're kind of you hold your finger on
they're not tight not actually tight but
just hold your finger on there then that
will secure it it's not going to flip
off and once it a number two and go up
on the top just go forward that goes
with the grace so going forward and if
that should you don't have to be over
neat with this part because you just
produce him in there and you might
actually putting it down to the level he
wants yet anyway so you just kind of
like just getting rid of all of this
bulk majority of people the hair at the
top will grow this way hair on the side
will go down it might be slightly to one
side but going down they hand it back to
go down so now you're going to pull in
the direction that you say explaining so
basically that's what go forward on the
side go down you just producing the next
[Music]
reduce a little more that's cool amount
so little don't step to they're going to
put the barrier into where you gonna
start afraid I'm going to put a line
there and just pull a lot all the way
around Issei you're gonna play that line
now take it off so she's like that it's
difficult
that's the point of no return this is
the heck are you requesting yeah flatly
take it should be doing that that's how
you can someone know I mean I know it's
like I'm going I need you to not just
follow that line around on tape trying
to be gentle
[Applause]
you're doing well because he's not
complaining
you don't worry about like making it
like believe you know that's super sharp
line because you're gonna feed it
outside of the mouth so don't worry
about it all right not what I want you
to do is literally just all the excess
here at the bottom just get rid of it
now right now see all I hear was just
the right coach
okay look at that not a sympathy well no
we just started so now we're going to
get into the feed this is not step to
read didn't faint all in one go we're
going to break it down at the pot
basically imagine that isn't line here
I'm a gonna put the skin line there I'm
going to take the clip bar I'm going to
create a barrier coming from here just a
day and then you're going to figure out
that line there you must get up the top
part you're going to take your tip off
that are open it up so the knee but down
the bottom of the tip are worth open
great a bearing it's a little barrier
like like that's more come from
underneath the line through the line and
just stop and then create that fire in
the hole we run when I go up don't go
too far up don't up like about descent
you got this yeah up down up down up
down all around yet this is the so
subtle game right here
I didn't define it too much like it was
just like I let me just be careful but
it's better to be cautious because it is
you don't make mistakes you've got
confidence now and you can see what you
didn't do
go get it I this so from underneath the
line just go through the line and come
out go around go the whole way around
don't spend too much time trying to do
this I went all the way around the Ebro
a little bit more push it down a little
bit more into exactly the same thing
come from underneath the line through
the line flick out
[Music]
yes that's cool lower it more and do
that same thing in the hallway mouth you
see the line disappearing yeah
all right you're doing the right thing
all right and then one more time
literally one more time bring it down a
little bit more and you're doing good
now you're going a good piece of rock
you're not over doing it or overthinking
it they're confident shining through boy
[Music]
step four is now the top part if you
left you're gonna fade anything on the
sides here take the number one gonna
move the grain energy going down I just
want you to let them eat his hair on the
side take up as much as will come off so
this really did ignite just literally
reducing the wok at this point here you
need to create an invisible line your
invisible line is saying I am NOT gonna
go any higher than that line because
right now you can end up fading it and
then end up waiting up here then you
give them a Mohican sometimes I talk
beginners take the comb and literally
just put a soft line in it at least even
if you don't remember what you can do
see exactly I'm not gonna pop that line
ah okay okay so let me now overthink
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
why do you do now is the same number one
you're gonna open it so the leader
should be at the bottom open and then
you're gonna go from where the Box Tops
I know from the the line you crazy
amounts of the way I might is you're
gonna come from underneath the line
through the line and it gets you a bit
of a line click out so the motion will
be literally so exactly the same thing
what you doing before but now you do it
with a different number care and your
stroke is longer now flick up quick to
face and get the cone in a boxer like
come you tear up when you go through it
now you're going to change the direction
of his head so the cone brings it back
looking good looking good looking good
what I've seen there is his hair is on
it not lying flat so when you've gone up
with the Clipper we have a comb it back
down so when I saw it I see some areas
on it looking blended but it could blend
a lot more so every time you go up calm
down
you gotta do like in the bar the comb is
your friend looking nice yeah so now we
need to do is close the leaver it's
gonna take off more hair to come in make
sure your comb in your combing - combing
and then go through it don't stick out
[Music]
felipito breakdown you should be you
should be
we got custody tonight okay talk to Joe
this area here we can see the line on
the head right there when you're going
to lick the hell you got coming up with
that areas focus on just touching that
line cuz it's heavy so you're gonna go
through it with a number one all you
want is that able to be a little bit
like a good play so do the side piece
and then comb in the direction is
burning hi this is goodness this fate is
gonna get at home and we're gonna hop on
to the next lesson bye mark alright
step 5 the shape up now when you're
gonna shake them up all you need to do
before you actually put the shape up
we'll start the shape up should I say is
literally make sure that the front of
his hair is flat so take the number one
and if you just run over the edges just
to make sure it's flat but your shape up
cos but wherever you see the line is
that's waiting it's going to touch it
you're not going to worry about trying
to get a shock they're not gonna worry
about trying to get it straight
all you're gonna weigh back is literally
touching the edge of whatever this is
basically go further on the shape it up
just touch it and the second round is
coming okay what can I can I make a
sharper can I improve it can I make it
straight up but and your first round
literally just touch the H it creates
some [ __ ] for you to go on press down
you said and put away but literally just
kinda like
this touching it and also on the sides
same thing you put in a waste of AC
you're always trying to pull away from
the hair how's it looking now better
well like you said it's not about making
a sharper but I feel like absolutely see
from the front of these things people
where he put it with those people what
you want to do is just follow a line
touching it going on it's in a straight
line across once you do that and be fine
that detects I'll be fine I wanna wants
me yes please
again I think there's still a slight
issue yes boss
well I would say is to basically leave
it that's at the point isn't you're not
going out and it's not like a
professional job no offense to you know
just it's good to be a customer in a
place when he or she decides to go to
their Baba their problems won't be like
oh why did he pull your hair all the way
back here you could stay here all day
trying to improve it and that's when
you're not making mistakes the whole
point is that you can do
to a decent level that you have the only
thing we need to do now is literally the
help set up quietly back there
so you take another one and just you
know lower the hair did you say end
resort it looks better than hide up
before it looks clean up he looks neat
up in the beginning everything is super
slow and then towards the end is picked
it up and the form got better
your handling got better the technique
got better you know if you have that
same technique in the beginning then
it'll be quicker haircut and makeup will
be even better which means that the next
haircut you do you can cut again I'm
working with now real clean no smooth I
think I did a great job I know I could
have done it
greater glad we have mark to walk us
through because there's so many little
details and stuff that I feel like we
didn't know about that just make all the
difference the best thing I can tell you
is to mess up and be comfortable with
mess enough cuz that's how you get
better and if you can get ahold of mark
go ahead
peace